[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est 4 heures du matin je suis sur une
paroi dans les alpes à 3800 mètres
d'altitude
le couloir est raide froid et verglas
s'est tu progresses petit à petit en
pointe avant avec mes piolet ya 600
mètres de vide sous moi et un peut-être
plus de 200 m pour atteindre le sommet
ça fait déjà plusieurs heures qu'on est
parti du refuge pour tenter de gravir
les aiguilles vertes
soudain j'ai une douleur fulgurante dans
le mollet droit suivie par une autre
quatre secondes après dans la cuisse
droite toute ma jambe se met à trembler
je me dépêche de sortir une broche à
glace est de m'assurer sur la paroi et
là c'est ma jambe gauche qui se
tétanisent complètement impossible à
arrêter
j'ai tellement mal que le sua de données
va nuire au bout d'un quart d'heure la
douleur passe et la corde et continue sa
progression dans la paroisse et en
arrivant au sommet je me suis dit
mathieu plus jamais ça tu vas tu
améliorée bonsoir je m'appelle mathieu
laine ce je suis directeur marketing
dans le big data et cofondateur d'une
plate formes d'acculturation
intelligence artificielle
alors je suis pas un alpiniste
professionnel mais je suis passionné de
haute montagne et d'ultra trail et je me
suis demandé si on combine ans mais
constantes vitales avec mes données
biométriques plus quelques données météo
données satellites et quelques millions
d'autres données patient je pourrais pas
créer un algorithme d'intelligence
artificielle qui me fasse une une sorte
de diagnostic prédictif et en temps réel
elle pourrait me dire par exemple où la
matu attention ça va pas tant manque de
sel fait quelque chose mon grand moi j
saucisson
autrement dit est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle peut nous améliorer et nous
aider à dépasser nos limites
est-ce que ça concerne tout le monde
alors ce soir je vais vous livrer mes
réflexions sur le sujet il ya ce que ça
concerne tout le monde donc à l'issue de
ce texte vous allez sortir
vous allez rallumer vos portables de la
pl notification 10 dont un stade pour
les jeunes facebook pour les vieux
linkedin pour les fous du boulot vous
avez remarqué ça c'est une intelligence
artificielle qui est nouveau poste dans
votre flux d'actualité que ce qui vous
correspond réellement à la limite peu
importe on va se détendre une dernière
fois on va aller profiter des soldes sur
amazon qui non seulement c'est ce que je
préfère mais commence déjà à livrer le
produit avant même que je n'ai cliquer
sur le bouton acheter
grâce à ce nouveau rythme dia prédictif
ya ça concerne tout le monde est liée à
ça va vite
en 2010 8 65 mille articles
scientifiques ont été publiés par les
états unis la chine et l'europe réunis
deux fois plus qu'en 2015 60 5680
articles par jour sachant qu'on peut
lire qu un article par jour un article
c'est 15 à 30 pages dans un anglais très
technique faut s'accrocher croyez moi on
est déjà complètement dépassée alors et
l'homme dans tout ça l'homme augmenté ou
la femme augmenté yeux l'homme augmenté
avec un grand h le mouvement t
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle et sa porte
même un nom ça s'appelle le
transhumanisme troisième à nice mme
c'est un projet d'amélioration de
l'espèce humaine sous toutes les formes
qu'elle soit morale intellectuelle
physique ou émotionnel
les membres bionique l'utérus artificiel
les exosquelettes les apens cérébraux le
rallongement de la durée de la vie la
thérapie génique encore le contrôle de
notre apparence ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que l'homme est un être
technologique depuis des dizaines de
milliers d'années ils créent des outils
pour pallier les manques dont la nature
l'a doté
l'homme est voué à s'améliorer
le philosophe jean jacques rousseau
disait l'homme est un être perfectible
aujourd'hui la technologie peut donner à
l'homme a encore augmenté
alors ce soir je vous donnais quatre
exemples pour bien comprendre la chose
premier exemple on se trouve à grenoble
au centre de recherche clinatec en 2019
un exosquelette a permis un tape
patients tétraplégiques de remarcher
grâce à une neuroprothèses le patient
pense le mouvement et la machine
s'activent
attention c'est un système très simple
on entraîner le cerveau des mois et des
mois durant à exhiber un certain nombre
d'états cérébraux que la machine a
ensuite traduit en mouvement donc on est
très loin du contrôle par la pensée mais
c'est assez extraordinaire lorsque
l'homme s'hybrident avec la machine
on appelle ça un homme cyborg un mélange
d'organismes biologiques et de greffe
mécanique électronique
il ya six ans une entreprise française
car matt réalisé la première
intervention chirurgicale d'implantation
d'un coeur artificiel total
bioprothétiques autorégulé aujourd'hui
c'est plus d'une douzaine de patients en
insuffisance cardiaque qui vivent grâce
à cette innovation l'homme fonctionne
désormais grâce au processus propre de
la machine et l'homme fonctionne grâce à
la machine
troisième exemple la rétinopathie
diabétique en france ça concerne 1,5
million de personnes
c'est la première cause de cécité avant
65 ans une entreprise américaine a
inventé une intelligence artificielle
capable de dépister cette dégénérescence
avant qu'elle n'arrive mais le plus
intéressant c'est pas ça l'association
américaine du médicament la fda a
autorisé pour la première et unique fois
au monde
ce dispositif médical à la vente et en
décembre 2019 c'est l'association
américaine des diabétiques qui va
inclure cetia autonome dans ses
standards de soins
concrètement ça vous dit ça veut dire
quoi ce que je vous dis là ça veut dire
que la machine remplace le médecin est
c'est officiel c'est un standard sécu ça
me rappelle quelqu'un qui voulait
développé un algorithme médias pour la
montagne tout ça dernier exemple selon
l'insee et si tout se passe bien s'il
n'y a pas de guerre ce n'est pas de
cataclysme n'y a pas d'épidémie
une petite fille née aujourd'hui à 48 %
de chances de devenir centenaire
et grâce aux progrès de la techno
médecine des recherches sur les cellules
souches ou des recherches relier les
télomérase
ces enzymes qui sont capables de
prévenir l'usure des chromosomes qui est
un des facteurs de la liesse
rien n'empêcherait de vivre jusqu'à 120
150 ans voire plus comme le suggère le
roi alexandre la mort est un problème et
on a une solution
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'il faut continuer à améliorer
l'être humain de manière artificielle ou
pas lorsqu'il faut que vous ratiez ce
soir c'est qu'il ya deux camps qui
s'opposent
vous avez d'un côté les bio progressiste
qui veulent lutter contre les trois
fléau de l'humanité que sont la maladie
la vieillesse et la mort et de l'autre
côté vous avez les bio conservateurs
pour lesquels la nature est sacrée la
changer ou la modifier revient à la
destruction de nos principes moraux
fondamentaux bio progressiste bio
conservateur les deux ont des arguments
identiques
qu'est-ce que moi j'en ai retenu l'homme
augmenté déjà là qu'on le veuille ou non
aujourd'hui il ya plus de différence
entre de médecine thérapeutique qui
répare ce qui est cassé qui soigne la
maladie ou qui restera l équilibre et
une médecine à méliorative qui va
stimuler notre système immunitaire qui
va lutter contre le processus de ces
naissances ou qui va améliorer notre
silhouette et aujourd'hui il n'y a rien
qui empêcherait la machine de dépasser
l'homme surtout les grands principes de
penser comme l'imagination à synthèse ou
l'intentionnalité intentionnalité le
fait d'être conscient d'exister
la machine nous a déjà dépassé sur la
déduction et l'induction
est-ce que je vais développer mon
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle
pour m'aider à gravir les sommets
et bien non je vais pas le développer je
laisse idées à d'autres
parce que ce qui m'intéresse moi dans la
montagne et l'alpinisme
c'est pas le classement c'est pas
l'efficacité à tout prix c'est pas
d'atteindre le sommet à chaque fois mais
c'est vraiment de me sentir vivant avec
mes propres limites et ses limites
justement qui motive pour essayer de les
dépasser et par rapport à la machine
j'ai quelque chose qu'elle n'aura jamais
jamais c'est à dire un corps le corps
est capable de choses incroyables si on
les écoute
faites lui confiance car il se souvient
de tout il est en mémoire des millions
de gestes et de pause le corps dispose
d'une avance incroyable sur la machine
et même si la machine pourra peut-être
nous remplacer sur les grands principes
de penser elle ne remplacera jamais les
actes du corps regardez vos mains vos
mains on 360 millions d'années le pouce
opposable pour la préhension 55 millions
d'années
nos corps ont été fascinée depuis les
origines de la vie le philosophe michel
serres disaient qu'ils inventent le
corps expérimente le corps intelligence
reste bête est lourde sans le corps ce
soit entre bio progressistes et
conservateurs j'ai fait mon choix la
meilleure façon de devenir un homme
augmenté c'est de se reconnecter à son
corps alors ce soir à tous je vous pose
la question et vous
quel est votre choix merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]